Today we're kicking it off with a miracle Ross.
It really is the story.
You're not going to believe it.
It starts back in 2013.
Two women named Julia and Cassandra,
met while working at a bar.
Julia told Cassandra
that she loved her Dominican flag tattoo
and that she was Dominican too.
Born there and adopted there.
And then Cassandra said, "Whoa, me too."
And they became best friends.
They wear matching outfits.
They told people they were sisters just for fun.
And then they even compared their adoption papers
to see if by some bizarre chance they actually were sisters
but the documents didn't match up.
Oh well, they stayed besties for years.
Well then people reports
that Julia eventually took a DNA test
and found her biological dad.
And he revealed
that he did have another daughter in the United States.
Wow.
And they just ran the DNA test on Cassandra and yup,
full biological sisters.
Wow.
That somehow found each other
at a bar in New Haven, Connecticut.
And it turned out there were just errors
in Julia's adoption papers to begin with.
Yeah I mean, this is unbelievable story.
It's like what you dream about, you know
finding out that there's some connection.
I always wanted to find out that I was like, you know,
princess Diaries.
I'm princess of Genovia somehow (laughing)
you know, but when I was reading this,
I mean, I've never talked about this ever.
A lot of my friends don't even know.
But I was so envious
that they found each other because you know
I've lost both my parents
and my connection with my brother who I have is
I have learned that family is the most important thing
in the entire world.
And
I have a relative who is out there
who was given up for adoption
and it's somebody who
my parents never got a chance to track down.
And I read this and I thought to myself,
how lucky are these two women that they found each other?
You know,
when you don't know where your family is,
it haunts you.
I think about it every day.
And I'm so envious of them
and it really ignited something in me.
I'm really gonna try to do what my parents never finished.
I really wanna to find this person
Ross, is there anything that I can do?
Or, you know, if you'd like to start this journey privately
or as your friend or if there's you know,
anything that I can do?
Yeah. I don't know.
I didn't put that much thought into it.
I just said it right now. (laughing)
I don't know so yeah.
I mean, I want to.
The thing is, is that it's clueless.
Like if you wanna start this kind of search,
how do you do it?
I don't know.
So maybe I'll spend a little time with Google
and we can throw some ideas around
but yeah I have no idea how to do it.
Well, sometimes the beginning of a journey
is just realizing that the timing is now
and if it is and it's okay if it's not
but if it is
then we just start.
Okay, I think it is.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's begin this journey.
Okay.
(audience clapping)
We'll see what happens, right?
Well, congrats to them, you know,
sorry I didn't mean to steal your thunder ladies
but congratulations.
(audience laughing)
All right it's not about me, it's about you,
but thank you for that gift.
I think that's an incredible story.
I think it might be about you
the fact that there is a story
which is so extraordinary has sparked and inspired
maybe a clock for you because timing is everything.
It is.
Things happen for a reason.
Just like they were put in that bar for a reason.
Maybe I read their story,
you read it here for a reason as well.
That's exactly right Ross.
Yeah
And we have a lots more news.
I know you're gonna love this story Drew
because you know, we're obsessed with Bridgerton.
Well, it's the gift that keeps on giving.
CNN reports that one small business owner,
accredits Bridgerton with a runaway success
of her new venture.
Stephanie Sinclair started her tea company LaRue 1680,
smack in the middle of the pandemic
and just I hope for the best.
And then Bridgerton happened and Stephanie got inspired.
She created a tea collection based on what
a Duke and Duchess might drink
and her business took off like 500% increase in revenue.
And you know, we love this story.
We love Bridgerton and growing up like I didn't drink tea.
Like maybe I had a Snapple on occasion that was like it
which I'm not mad at.
But in adulthood,
drinking tea has become such a little like luxury for me.
It's very ritualistic.
Right, you totally feel fancy
but it's like a center bag and her tea right here.
Look how beautiful this package is.
I mean, look at this.
Yeah, so it's loose leaf, which scares me.
Oh my God, I know that really is adult.
It's totally adult.
I don't even have one of these things.
I'm rocking the Casablanca, what are you rocking?
Yeah, I'm having a Casablanca as well
and it's so delish and robust, right?
I wanna describe what is happening.
I feel like I'm drinking a Rose garden.
Yes.
So floral.
I don't even understand what it is--
But also acidic and beautiful
the way you'd want like a hibiscus tea.
Mines like empty.
I'm already downed it.
Oh my gosh, this is going in the little yellow book
this is the best tea ever.
Stephanie congratulations.
Oh, Stephanie Sinclair good for you.
Wow okay, I'm not kidding.
Wait until you try this.
It's like, it's a whole experience.
It's not just a tea.
(laughing)
It's not just for tea.
Okay and now it is time to taste the good news in food news.
(audience cheering)
Okay, Delish reports that Reese's
is taking their famous peanut butter cups
and turning them monochromatic
with the ultimate peanut butter lovers cups.
Oh my God.
Bye bye chocolate, this is a full peanut butter party
PB on the outside, PB on the inside.
What are you doing to me?
These Reese's cups are a gateway candy for Ross Matthews.
I can't believe you're bringing this out for me.
Rossi, I can do it if you're worried.
Cause you really are like you're committed
and I'm like all over the place.
I'm so grateful that you do that for me as a friend,
but if you reach over here, I will smack your hand, okay?
(audience laughing)
You know we love peanut butter, so let's go.
I mean what I said.
Oh my God.
You're never gonna want your old one again.
This is leaps and bounds
Stephanie, Reese's thank you.
(upbeat music)